اضار تقرير لجنه الوزاريه للسلامه
المروريه في السعوديه عن انخفاض اعداد
الحوادث الجسيمه في العام 2022 بنسبه
تقترب من السبعه في المئه مقارنه بالعام
2021 في الوقت الذي ارتفعت فيه حوادث
السلفيات بنسبه 28% وصلت جدل حول ارتفاع
يساره
السلامه المروريه خلال العام الماضي في
السعوديه تقرير اصدرته اللجنه الوزاريه
والسلامه المروريه اخيرا اظهر نتائج ملف
السلامه المروريه التقرير بينا انخفاض
اعداد المتوفين نتيجه الحوادث حيث بلغت
اربعه الاف و 555 متوفى بنسبه انخفاض بلغت
اثنين فاصله واحد في المئه مقارنه بالعام
2020 اعداد المصابين نتيجه الحوادث هي
الاخرى انخفضت حيث بلغت في العام الماضي
اكثر من 24,000 مسجله انخفاضا بنسبه اثنين
فاصل سبعه في المئه عن العامل الذي سبقه
الحوادث الجسيمه ايضا سجلت انخفاضا بنسبه
6.8% مقارنه بالعام 2021 حيث بلغت في
العام الماضي
16000 و900 حادثه جسيمه
اما الارتفاع الوحيد فكان من نصيب حوادث
التلفيات حيث بلغت في العام الماضي اكثر
من مليون و 800000 بارتفاعا يقدر ب 28% عن
العام 2021
ورغم ان الارقام تعكس فعاليه الانظمه
والتزام السائقين للتقليل من الحوادث
المروريه وما يتبعها الا ان الارتفاع
الكبير الذي حل بارقام حوادث السلفيات قد
يكون من اهم الاسباب التي دفعت اسعار
التامين على المركبات الارتفاع غير معهود
في السوق السعوديه اذ اقتربت نسبه
الارتفاع الى الضعف تقريبا وسط استياء
عاما بين ملاك المركبات خصوصا من يؤكد ان
سجله خادم من الحوادث لكنها ميزه لم تحميه
من غلاء الاسعار الذي طال الجميع